hey was geht ab und jetzt bekommen beim
neuen video
ich habe heute so eigentlich die ganze
welt liegt ob ich dazu ein video machen
soll oder nicht weil es auf der einen
seite so ich kann wie du darüber machen
ob so was jetzt auf youtube gehört ob
ich so etwas in die öffentlichkeit
es ist eine andere frage aber ich habe
jetzt einfach gedacht so ich mein es ist
ja eigentlich wegen youtube dazu kommen
wieso sollte ich dann nicht auf youtube
video dazu machen ihr habt hier
wahrscheinlich am titel auch schon
gelesen es geht um irgendein anzeige
ob ich jetzt angezeigt wurde nicht
deswegen habt ihr wahrscheinlich das
video angeklickt um das zu erfahren
obwohl warte mal ist schiffer will auch
keiner habe ich den titel männer auf
jeden fall glaubt coolste sache noch ich
weiß übrigens ganz woanders aber bevor
wir weitermachen wo ich noch schnell
sagen ich weiß nicht ob es gesehen habe
aber ich hab' neues kanal design danke
da mal an emilio und sein team steckt
auf jeden fall mal in der video
beschreibung ein paar links ab zudem
emilio und seinem team also sagen
designer team das auf jeden fall ein
cooles cooles denke da ich mal und
lastet man aber da keine ahnung hat mich
sehr gefreut dank für das design ich bin
mega cool und jetzt machen wir weiter
ich fange jetzt einfach man also ich
habe ja in letzter zeit ziemlich viele
videos gemacht und auch ziemlich viele
videos jetzt zum beispiel einfach mal
music ally reaction worauf sich das
heutige video eigentlich auch bezieht
oder ich hab halt daraus naja mit
musical ist daraus ein video gestaltet
und ich hab halt content benutzt der
jetzt nicht unbedingt so zu 100 prozent
mir gehört eigentlich zu null prozent
aber ich habe mir gedacht zu kommen
alles was auf music kelly ist legte
schon zum teil im besitz von musical und
was will mir die plattform dann groß
wenn ich das in meinem youtube video
zeige ich meine das pusht das ganze ja
eigentlich so ein bisschen sage ich mal
oder sie profitieren ja in gewisser
weise von ich meine die videos haben
jetzt bestimmt alle musical wii action
soll music gegend wo musical drin ist ja
bestimmt insgesamt 23 millionen views
gemacht so wenn nicht sogar mehr keine
und ich habe eigentlich immer darauf
geachtet dass die leute die ich jetzt in
meinem video habe nicht aus deutschland
kommen weil ich finde es scheiße wenn
zum beispiel jetzt irgendeinen 12 13
jähriger richtig grottenschlechtes news
viele gemacht hat oder irgendwas ja
wisst ihr wohl schlecht dasteht und ich
das dann im deutschen youtube brauchen
verbände und dass seine schulfreunde
sehen das hatte ich auch schon mal aber
ich hab's halt einfach so raus genommen
und ihr wisst was ich meine
also ich habe ein wenig stoff geachtet
dass es leute aus dem amerikanischen
raum sind da bin ich wirklich auf die
profile gegangen habe nachgeschaut oder
leute aus keine ahnung china sonst wo
die halt wirklich in keinerlei kontakt
mit deutschland stehen oder hat ja ich
meine wo soll da der sinn legen dass sie
halt auch dieses musical i angesprochen
werden weil es im video von alex wie es
obwohl sie in china wo jetzt gerade
haben wir montag und letzten freitag
oder donnerstag keine ahnung
bei uns zuhause post an und die post
ging an mich und ich dachte hey was
wollen die ihnen jetzt von mir habe ich
irgendwie muss sich gegen den antrag
stellen oder sonstwas und abgeguckt und
irgendetwas oder irgendjemand den ich
nicht kenne hat mich wohl angetan ich
zeig euch das jetzt einfach mal so sieht
das aus ich weiß nicht ob es das licht
ist ganz schön hell kleinen moment so
sieht das ganz so ungefähr aus wir
wenden wollte erzählt darin sehr
geehrter herr burger am 12 10 216 mutter
auf ihrem youtube kanal folgendes video
veröffentlicht musicals zum fremdschämen
herrscht ergraute zwei einleiten heißt
es unter anderem minute 312 bis 325
verstoßen ach so ich kann das nicht von
glück machen keiner minute 312 bis
minute 23 verstoßen gegen das
urheberrecht des eigentümers es gilt
folgendes es liegt uns eine strafanzeige
vor ort lenzing bostons boston
streetwork michigan die sich paragraf
was die sich auf paragraf 51 des
deutschen urheberrechtsgesetzes bezahlt
das geld verstoß gegen paragraf 57
rufschädigung des eigentümers erwähnen
12 bis 12
keine anwalt das immer so kompliziert
geschrieben es liegt uns vor der
eigentümer des youtube kanals alex wie
doppelpunkt mein name babbel war anlage
urheberrechtsverletzung formular
unterschrift also das ist das so in
proben
das ist das einzige was ich gerade habe
ich habe keine ahnung ob jetzt geld
bezahlen muss
ob ich keine ahnung weiß ich nicht das
steht ja nicht mehr drin lässt sich das
video löschen sollte unbedingt aber ich
denke das wäre angebracht ich weiß es
nicht ich war das erst mal einfach nur
ab und ich bin wirklich mal gespannt was
damit passiert ich finde natürlich ja
okay es war erstmal so dachte ich so he
also ich würde auch nie angezeigt ich
hätte auch nie gedacht dass irgendwann
in meinem leben war angezeigt werde
aber ja ich hoffe das ist wirklich eine
einmalige sache und es bezieht sich nur
auf das video und nicht auf irgendwelche
anderen videos die jetzt auch noch von
irgendwelchen leuten da gemeldeten ich
habe wirklich keine ahnung wie jemand
aus amerika ist kann eigentlich nur ist
steht er sogar michigan wie man wie
kommt man das weiß ich nicht so wie man
auf dieses video kommt oder wer das
heißt eigentlich schon dass ich
zuschauer aus und amerikanischen raum
hab so was ich voll krass finde ich
musste kurzen kleinen location wechsel
machen
ich war ja gestern noch in köln jetzt
bin ich wieder bei meiner freundin ich
muss jetzt hier das video weiterführen
auf jeden fall absolut zu dem thema noch
mal ziemlich viele gedanken gemacht und
damit ihr einfach mehr versteht ja wie
das ganze so zustande kam warum ich
jetzt genau dazu ein video machen wollte
ich einfach mal kurz auf zum beispiel
das video von sam mendes zu verweisen
das habe ich gestern gläubige screenshot
er hat gesagt ja ich hätte auch wirklich
100 andere videos nehmen können ich habe
mich jetzt einfach mal für das
entschieden
ich glaube das kennen die meisten von
euch und zwar redezeit mit lästigen
wieder von soja meine videos oder 60
meiner videos von claimed weil ich
anderes material was mich gehörten
reingenommen ab was natürlich auch jeder
weiß und deswegen soll jetzt meinen
kanal gelöscht werden weil ich auch
unter anderem dieses pendler benutzer
frage bleibt war natürlich riesig ich
weiß ich glaube das video hat schon eine
millionen views gerade also gerade ist
ob mir das jetzt glaubt oder nicht ist
eure sache wir haben dienstag 13 uhr
morgen kommt auch ein placement deswegen
kommt dieses video am donnerstag online
und ich weiß nicht was in der hinsicht
da noch passiert auf jeden fall wie
gesagt haben dass er sagt wenn channel
wird gelöscht
worauf ich erst mal sagen kann
nein niemals dieses video bekommt einen
unglaublichen hype wirklich ein so
krassen hey leute denkt doch mal nach
youtube löschen youtube kanal mit drei
millionen abonnenten weil er ab und zu
mal so macht oder sonst war er redet zum
beispiel davon dass bei drei geklärten
videos der channel eigentlich schon weg
ist
ich habe auch zehn locker zehn geklemmt
videos aber ich habe mir noch nie sorgen
darum gemacht dass mein channel gelöscht
wird geklebt oder nicht geklärt ist
scheissegal was den channel betrieb klar
wenn man jetzt 60 gekränkte videos hat
könnte es vielleicht passieren dass man
in strike bekommt weil 60 ist schon viel
aber youtube löscht keinen channel mit
drei millionen abonnenten mann bevor wir
jetzt weitermachen ich muss erst mal
kurz aufstehen weil meine beine
einschlagen aber ich wollte auch was
anderes sagen ich persönlich cook gar
nicht so viele andere youtuber
adersheimer desto finde ich witzig der
teilt meine nummer oder ich kann bei
fast jedem seiner videos lachen und das
finde ich ist ist das darum geht's
youtube aber zurzeit ist einfach so ich
gehe einmal in die youtube trends in
deutschland herunter und kann sagen weg
weg weg weg weg weg weg weg weg
diese 24 stunden videos und da gibt es
auch natürlich schon mega viele videos
auf youtube muss einfach mal kurz klar
stellen entweder ist es abgesprochen weg
oder ist es illegal und einfach nur
komplett hier los und wenn ich dann
wirklich so ein video sehe das absolut
100% fake ist und dass 90.000 likes hat
und sagen wir mal 3000 vielleicht 5000
dislike sein denke ich möchte leute ist
es euer ernst dieses video hier was ihr
gerade von mir schaut ist nicht
monetarisiert habt ihr vielleicht auch
schon gemerkt es war keine werbung am
anfang ich will damit wirklich überhaupt
kein geld verdienen ich mache es einfach
weil ich das gefühl habe dass wachen zu
muss weil weil es mich einfach so
aufregt so ihr habt auf dieses video
geklickt weil im titel stetig wurde
angezeigt und ich glaube ich drei vier
fünf minuten darüber erzählt habe wie
ich angezeigt wurde
wie es dazu kam warum das so kam und
keine ahnung war es irgendwann bin ich
dann vom thema abgewichen und bin auf
andere videos eingestiegen und ich kann
euch jetzt sagen ich wurde nicht
angezeigt
ich wollte einfach nicht angezeigt so
das war einfach so eine arbeit von 20
minuten das zu felgen und ich glaube
bestimmen 95 prozent von euch haben das
geglaubt bis dahin wo ich vielleicht auf
andere videos verwiesen habe oder nicht
seit bei ehrlich
schreibt man bitte jetzt in die
kommentare das geglaubt hätte hätte ich
das einfach so weiter durchgezogen
oder ob jetzt nicht geglaubt ich meine
es gibt ja kein grund es nicht zu
glauben ich mal ich glaube ich hab's
ganz gut rüber gebracht so die intention
dieses videos waren nicht mehr komplett
andere ja nur ich wollte damit einfach
gerade mal zeigen mit was für eine
scheiße man auf youtube seinen
lebensunterhalt verdienen kann ich meine
es gibt einmal das fernsehen und es gibt
einmal youtube fernsehen so da laufen
serien im fernsehen da weiß man er da
ist alles gescriptet alles fällt youtube
gibt es und youtube hält sich so gut
weil er so viele personen über ihr
eigenes leben erzählen
irgendwie keine ahnung coolen content
machen der keinerlei fake ist aber
gerade sind irgendwie 50 prozent auf
youtube denke ich mir so einfach
schauspieler die irgend ne scheiße
labern und jeder glaubt ist wisst ihr
was ich meine ich wollte damit einfach
mal mit zeigen wie schade findet dass
diese realen ist keine ahnung ob das
wort gibt aber das geht einfach verloren
finde ich gerade das geht ganz einfach
aber ich finde es schade wenn es weitere
erfolgskonzept von youtube deutschland
sein sollte dann finde ich natürlich
schade ich kann euch allerdings
versichern ich bei brühl
auch wenn sich das mal scheiße sein und
ich finde ich bleibe video wichtig
willst keine ahnung hat sehr
wahrscheinlich sein so also schreibt
jetzt um eine kommentare habt ihr mir
das geglaubt oder nicht ich habe die
bewertung ganz bewusst ausgestellt und
in diesem video jetzt müsste ich gerade
mal die speicherkarte wechsel auf jeden
fall wir sehen uns wieder am sonntag
beim 1 bio 14 uhr
ich freue mich auf euch und verdrängt